What I'm going to do is introduce a new concept that we didn't see before
in our initial listing of the concepts,
but which is an important one--the notion of a prefix of a word.
It's important only for efficiency and not for correctness--that's why it didn't show up the first time.
The idea is that given a word there are substrings, which are prefixes of the word.
The empty string is such a prefix. Just W is a prefix.
W-O is a prefix. W-O-R is a prefix.
Now, we always have to decide what we want to do with the endpoints.
I think for the way I want to use it I do want to include the empty string as a valid prefix,
but I think I don't want to include the entire string W-O-R-D.
I'm not going to count that as a prefix of the word. That is the word.
I'm going to define this function prefixes(word). It's pretty straightforward.
Just iterate through the range, and the prefixes of W-O-R-D are the empty string
and these three longer strings.
Now here's the first bit that I want you to do for me.
Reading in our list of words from the dictionary is a little bit complicated
in that we want to compute two things--a set of words and a set of prefixes
for all the words in the dictionary.
The set together of prefixes for each word--union all of those together.
I'm going to put that together into a function readwordlist(), which takes the file name
and returns these two sets. I want you to write the code for that function here.